like people really like again for the
youngsters this may sound crazy people
really thought the internet was a fad
like actually
right and
i thought everybody would have a website
and every company and they did
social media really was weird like
people really didn't want it to happen
they thought it was awkward they thought
it was stupid they thought it was for
just kids
it's most people have a social network
right that they're involved in there's
not a business on earth that's not going
to have nft infrastructure it doesn't
make any sense it's technology right now
everyone's too fascinated on the art and
the collectibles part that's a tiny
thing everyone's focused on the art and
collectibles with a hint of utility like
i just did with vcon the nft is a ticket
it's gonna flip its utilities with a
hint of collectibility
everyone of delta you know your ticket
that might be worth three dollars
because it has some artists on it but
there's a million of them right so
of course they're gonna integrate it
there's no alternative
tick tock just made a major move and
they talked about a 50 50 split which
would be the first platform that's
coming for youtube's super generous ad
rev share that has been a major but i
think a reason why creators flock there
it pays the best uh right now it's
limited to big creators 100 000 and uh
what do you think in terms of your
predictions and tick tock gunning for
everybody right now
look i think they've done a really good
job i think first of all their algorithm
is based on the interest graph instead
of the social graph which is a huge
advantage and i believe in merit
so my favorite thing is to look at all
your tick tocks where this video got 17
views this one got 430 and this one got
1.9 million that feels like merit
everybody's instagram being around the
same numbers doesn't feel like merit and
so i think we're intoxicated by the
merit of it they've been very aggressive
they've
they've already won
and now they're just going to expand
that's what everybody does right so they
want on this thing now they're saying oh
you can make longer videos oh you can
write more like today i was like wait a
minute i can write more copy i missed
the headlines i've been in like a cocoon
for four months with vcon and series 2b
friends so they'll just create
everything and so
yeah i mean i think they're incredibly
aggressive they tend to they're still
acting like a small company they're
innovating innovating innovating
innovating and now they've got everybody
following them they're the clear leader
in my opinion of the attention graph
which i think is the most important
currency in the world and
i think it's a smart move
if you backstage you said something you
said that short form is a gateway to
long form so what would your strategy be
for that if you're making tick tocks
you're getting the short form reach
this long form substance in your opinion
and does that mean send people off
platform does that mean try to get tick
tock to get your account to 10 minutes
which is super interesting longer form
vertical video
what do you mean by short form as a
gateway to long form and what would the
tactics be in that
it means that a lot of long-form
creators don't focus on short form and
vice versa there's a reason i have one
hour keynote videos and one hour podcast
but also pound unlimited micro content
that's 10 seconds long
um
you can go very tactical and you know
you know a lot of people want to hear
that like should i make a tick tock that
says watch the rest on youtube it's less
about that people will find you they
become intrigued your url strategy on
all your social networks should be very
thoughtful i'm constantly changing them
based on whatever my objectives are
but it just means that the world of
content creating should be always
thought about as and and i notice that
everybody's into or
right people are insecure most of you
did not start on tick tock fast enough
because you didn't have followers on it
you didn't start on tick tock fast
enough because you had 80 000 followers
on instagram and you had zero on tick
tock and you didn't like that feeling
that's why celebrities lost the first
time around
so like the things that you made fun of
people for
on instagram you became on tick tock
and so
you know i just i think it's always and
everyone's an order like i'm already on
instagram
they love using like logical excuses
like gary i need to focus i'm like cool
knock yourself out i'll talk to you in
36 months when you're crying
you're focusing on losing
the lack of humility
and the
lack of interest in
putting in the work on the new thing
because you just figured out the last
thing is why most people don't grow
there's not an accident that i've been
winning on every platform for the last
15 years it's called humility and hard
work
you think i was pumped when i had a
million followers on twitter and
instagram came along i was pissed
i'm like i'm [ __ ] winning this bird
game
but i'm like [ __ ] everyone's gonna go
there so i need to go
you think i was pumped when
tiktok came along i was dominating the
gram
i was like that's where it's going to be
so the lack of humility and the lack of
like [ __ ] i don't want to learn this new
thing i just got this that's fine
there's a problem though what you want
has nothing to do with what the market
is doing
the market doesn't give a [ __ ] about
your feelings
the market's not like oh tyrone spent a
lot of time on [ __ ] instagram we
should not create tick tick-tock
you think god's thinking like that get
the [ __ ] out of here
you won
on youtube or you won on instagram doing
that to the person that was holding on
to twitter or facebook but then you're
mad when tick tock's doing it to you
the hypocrisy is deafening
powerful
that's it
come on
gary that's a great lead-in to uh by the
way i'm laughing so did you see this no
video hard drive crashed
that makes me laugh brutal i know right
you have to adjust to reality
you wanted some sort of video that's
right but the [ __ ] hard drive crashed
you got a pivot it's not a pivot yeah
life is life i'm pumped that you got a
blue check on instagram but here comes
tick tock to [ __ ] your [ __ ] up what are
you gonna do
[Music]
you're gonna sit and hope
i'm watching everybody like hope i hope
this tick tock thing doesn't happen all
of you got forced in technology will
beat your ass
i love all of you that don't think nfts
are coming you will lose
you're pumped at the markets down see
see nothing i'll see you in 2027.
yeah i love this leading to tick-tock
there's a lot of people in the room
[Applause]
that are
that are uh they're at they're at a
place where a lot of people doing really
well i mean some people starting out and
you always say if you've got you don't
got money but you got time that's your
goal you got to put the sweat activity
in but there's people in the room they
have money and i'd like to hear about
team garyvee
like and a lot of people think okay to
do this because you say i went on
tick-tock but part of the way you're
doing that is because people are
multiplying your content you're casting
vision can you speak into maybe
we team garyvee is pretty advanced now
yeah we start a little bit at the
beginning as you think about those i
would say what am i what about my first
hires how do i even do this higher right
at real estate or financial services but
okay how do i start you know where i get
my d rock where do i get the whole thing
speak to early stages of building that
team to help you grow with video
you need to hire people that do things
that you don't want to do
where do you find them
the internet
people
say things that drive me crazy because
they don't want to do it
as if you can't find it
are you telling me you're at this
conference and you can't find people
you don't know what fiverr is you don't
know how to post on linkedin you don't
know how to search terms on twitter like
people come up with excuses a lot of
people
a lot of people don't grow because they
want money to buy things
a lot of people's businesses don't grow
because they want the business to give
them money so they can get a corvette
or a second this is back to you've got
to find the thing you like
because if you're building a brand or
your thing to buy the yacht
you're not going to build a very big
thing
i'm just building the thing to build the
thing
it's more interesting for me to build
the thing than it is it's like this
some people love actually here's a great
comp this is this blew my mind one of
the most stunning things that happened
to me in my life my whole life
i've wanted to be a professional athlete
right
so
by fifth grade i was like [ __ ] i don't
think i can play for the jets
because kids have gotten much bigger and
stronger in fact i had such good
hand-eye coordination that i was [ __ ]
killing people in first and second and
third grade but somewhere around like
fifth grade i'm like why is everyone
twice my size now
and so i was like this might not be in
the cards and that's when i decided to
buy the jets but
i was like [ __ ] it if i can't play for
it i'll just own the whole [ __ ] thing
so now me and aj get into the sports
business and we have a big practice now
and when i realized that a lot of kids
play professional sports but they don't
love the game it was just their best way
to monetize that like blew my mind and i
mean really don't like it and like when
we recruit kids now i never want to
recruit a kid that doesn't love the game
because i don't think they're going to
be at the you know because we make our
money on the second and third contract
there's kids that sign that first
contract and it's a wrap you want to
know why people are out of the league in
three four years because they didn't
give a [ __ ] about the game
so for me
this thing that we're talking about
i don't want the things that come from
being the best entrepreneur in the world
i just want to be the best entrepreneur
in the world
so it goes to like do you love it
because if you don't you can't get there
and so a lot of people don't have a
drock or a team because they don't want
to spend the 53 000 on it because they
want to burka bag and they want to go to
tahiti and they want a [ __ ] lambo
you're taking the money out of your
business for your insecurities instead
of feeding the business to win the
[ __ ] game
people want to
look successful more than actually be
successful
back to why i make so much content about
self-esteem
the reason i focus on love and being
kind to yourself and the [ __ ] that i've
been talking about is that's the seed of
the whole game
if you need lambos and chains and
accolades and check marks and a million
followers to clog the holes that you
have in your soul
then you're gonna not be able to build
meaningful things because you're taken
out of your business instead of feeding
it
gary for stage two and this is kind of
a personal question
because i'm a case study for it you know
your influence has so i went from
making tech review videos from reviewing
tech doing tech tutorials and affiliate
marketing built a six figure income one
of the biggest pieces of advice as i'm
watching your content and i'm absorbing
is we put it back in we put it back in
my wife and i just looked at the numbers
in 2019 our income went down our
net was like nothing because we just
went and we went all in team 20 and then
in 2020 things forexed after making a
massive investment back in our business
we're now 23 people
um and we're trying to really follow
your model
63 pieces of content a day that free
deck that you have or whatever all of
the numbers i throughout are completely
arbitrary the number
and i need it i mean it you're talking
about the 86 pieces of content you know
gary yeah 73 four tick tocks a day all
of it all of it's arbitrary the number
is as much as humanly [ __ ] possible
they're more at-bats for attention and
opportunity
you know what's better than 100 push-ups
you like that one huh
but i love you know who i love the most
fitness people fitness entrepreneurs are
my favorite let me tell you why
they're so good at their craft
like right like
but then went to business they don't do
the thing they do in fitness
they like fitness entrepreneurs [ __ ] on
people because people want shortcuts in
fitness they want [ __ ]
implants they want [ __ ]
apple cider vinegar pills they want all
sorts of [ __ ] when the answer is put
the work in the gym and eat properly
like follow the model but then as
entrepreneurs you see these [ __ ] all
beefed up did everything [ __ ] perfect
i'm talking about the ones that don't
cheat i'm talking about doing it right
and then they come to business and
they're like what's the shortcut and i'm
like you know that there's no shortcut
in this [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you looking for shortcut in
this [ __ ]
right
it they fascinate me because they have
such a big chapter of their life they
know everyone's like
i spent 38 years looking for the
shortcoming like
they're like it's [ __ ] go in the gym
and [ __ ] eat properly [ __ ]
amen
so so back to content i'm like i don't
know
like some of you make really good tick
tocks but you don't do this like you
have to be contextual to the platform
you have to know who the audience is and
slang matters
right you have to understand you have to
put in the reps the content output like
you know everybody tries to use social
as distribution they make one piece of
content and post it everywhere that
completely doesn't work
you've got to contextualize and post
creative for the platform i've i've
given three talks today
flew in that's why i was able to make it
work because i'm super pumped about
surrounding this and i surrounded it all
three are different i have to read the
room
the co you know the philosophical shit's
the same but it's got to be different
right
it's like
it's all food but it's different
and you have to know your audience i
don't understand how people come with
[ __ ] youtube dna into tick-tock and
think it's going to work
the mindset's different the same person
the same human i'm not talking about age
and gender and race and religion the
same human being is a different consumer
on tick tock than they are on instagram
your mindset's different once passive
entertainment on linkedin it might be
information
it's all context
so level two garyvee
uh team garyvee yes and and so
uh
maybe break down i'm looking at taking
advantage of a little bit of advice how
you built the team how fast you're
trying to scale the team do you have
people running operating things editors
uh i mean every at this point everything
you know i and maybe some people that
are really paying attention my content's
a little bit down because beat friends
and vayner is exploding and i'm like uh
there's a lot for me to do there but
yeah i mean you know i film everything
yeah i film absolutely everything and
then we go into post-production
and we script the audio for the podcast
and we
and we have writers who take the words
like everything is me even you know
everything has to be made how many
people take it by the way that's a real
big point anybody here
who has a social media person post on
their behalf and write the copy
to this day
every single word
every single word on instagram twitter
tick tock every single word
in the copy is written
actually by me
i know people who like
immediately hire someone to post on
their behalf and write the copy as if
it's them
that's that apple cinnamon [ __ ]
gummies
so obviously i don't make the videos
but like half the videos in my whatsapp
with my team right now never get posted
because i don't like it
i don't like it
i think they missed the context i think
it's out of context i don't want to talk
about that right now because the world
is this
that and then i post it me
so
you know i think that people don't want
to do the work
but you can have tons of people around
you we we figured out document don't
create that was the big unlock just
[ __ ] film everything post produce
this is a good reason to start shows if
you look go you know this might really
help a lot of you go to youtube tonight
when you get back home put in my name
and sort by lowest views you will be
blown away how many little things i do
and have done no audience because i
wanted just the content from doing the
podcast
for my post-production
so like at this point in my career it's
awesome because i get to win twice back
in the day i would do it because i
wanted the content
now it's like a double win because i
know me being on a guest on an up and
coming show really helps them so i'm
giving love and roses and i'm getting my
content
but a lot of you say no to [ __ ]
because your humility's not in check
i still say yes to [ __ ] that a lot of
you pass on
because i out humble you
i'm only going to do joe rogan you
[ __ ] suck right now
the [ __ ] are you talking about you
should do everything
one is greater than zero
one is greater than zero i watch people
walking around thinking there's somebody
you know i got there was somebody at
vcon trying to get into somebody they're
like yo i got 18 000 followers on
instagram like what the [ __ ]
people get high on their own supply real
quick
real quick people walking around here
thinking there's somebody because they
got 230 000 followers on tick tock
so
humble the [ __ ] up [ __ ] will get better
[Applause]
gary one of the big things that holds
people back is self-consciousness but
specifically people that worry about how
am i gonna look on camera how am i gonna
sound on camera uh what would you say to
somebody who's just trembling with fear
to get on camera because of those
insecurities i say a lot of things it's
the core foundation of my content
the last seven years of my life have
been dedicated on trying to build
people's self-esteem
i sound crazy
not all that great i mean i've gotten a
little bit better looking but like you
know like
i'm not winning on that
like
so
like i don't like
high school ended
[Applause]
everybody has this too
like you know like people are like like
i'd laugh when i was like you know you
really suck at this i'm like you suck at
[ __ ] too
as if not everybody sucks
everybody in here sucks [ __ ] at so much
[ __ ] it's crazy
right
[ __ ]
and but you want the r i'll give you a
real answer to what i actually think
works
this is a wild answer to this in my
opinion but i've really started to zero
in
i'm gonna help you
jump over to hurdle the fear of how i
look how i sound
deploy compassion to those who [ __ ] on
you
[Music]
i think the reason i'm winning is when
somebody says you're an idiot you're a
scam you're full of [ __ ] you suck you're
ugly [ __ ] you
my my brain immediately goes to like man
for somebody to take time out
of their day
to come to my profile
to try to tear me down because they're
hurting so much inside i only have love
for them
i'm aware that we're in a societal place
right now where the way we respond to
people's hate is with hate back to them
but i just don't have that gear when i
get [ __ ] on i deploy love through the
form of compassion if you're able to do
that
you won't hear them
but that's why i've been pounding on
humility the reason i work is because
i've got this going on
for when i get a thousand comments
860 of them are a goat emoji
the other 140 are you're a scam artist
when you can't hear either you can move
when you only hear the goat stuff you
become vulnerable to the scam stuff
too many people want that affirmation
and that's why people become unhappy if
your values are based on people giving
you accolades then you become
susceptible to the tear down
i'm just attached to both
can't hear you i'm on the field the [ __ ]
am i going to worry about you cheering
or booing i'm on the [ __ ] field
you're eating popcorn
you're [ __ ] making videos you're
putting in work you're trying to win for
yourself you're worried about pants 97
in arkansas who's pissed
[ __ ] her
[Applause]
you